[Music]
shark weeks kind of a big deal okay
let's not overdo it shall we
no it's an annual tradition on the
Discovery Channel and it starts in just
a couple of days well I've decided to
beat the Discovery Channel to the punch
okay I'm sick of those guys always
scooping us trumping us with their Shark
Week exactly so all this week our show
will be presenting an even more
dangerous and deadly predator Shaquille
O'Neal that's right that's better
forget about Shark Week here's the first
installment of Shaq week
[Applause]
[Music]
so stay tuned we'll have a lot more a
Shack week shack we do it Shack week
[Music]
Shark Week yeah they don't care
[Laughter]